i am boba fett  left for dead on the sands of tattween  job i ruled with fear  [Music]  i intend to rule with respect  the book of boba fett streaming december  29th on disney plus  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  i am boba fett  [Music]  the book of boba fett streaming december  29th only on disney plus  i am not a bounty hunter  i've heard otherwise  i know that you sit on the throne of  your former employer  jabba ruled with fear  i intend to rule with respect  you were all once captains under jabba  the hutt  i'm here to make a proposal that's  mutually beneficial  why speak of conflict  when cooperation can make us all rich  what prevents us all from killing you  and taking what we want  if he had spoken such insolence to jabba  he'd have fed you to his menagerie  please  [Music]  speak freely  [Music]  [Applause]  you